you've done so much great work in comedy
and then uh starting with breaking bad
you've morphed into this and now
nebraska you've morphed into this whole
acting career which is fantastic came
out of my cocoon
uglier than i was
but life is good let's see you've got
you've got two kids yes 13 and 15. yeah
is that right yeah have they seen you
prepared are they watching now they you
know most of the stuff that i've done is
a little
it's for mature sensibilities
you know it's got the language and uh
oftentimes bloody outcomes right so they
don't know me from tv mostly they know
me from uh
the kitchen um
where they know me as the angry
scowling father yes
there's a lot of uh language there in
the kitchen
they've heard but i've actually i
pitched some shows i wanted my kids to
see me on tv and i thought what could
they see me in that would be good for
them also so i you know i pitch shows i
try to sell shows i sold i tried to sell
a show called uh listen to your mother
just me saying come on
start listening that's the whole show
you write the case well they're dancers
dance oh there's dancers too there's ice
dancers oh great
and a show called it was a it was a show
uh called where to put things away
i never had i i thought if a british
narrator did it it might work yeah yeah
t-shirts
do they belong on the floor
history tells us no
there's a special drawer
i think you're going to sell both of
these shows i would love to sell and
then there was i wanted to if they could
get a doctor to do a show called uh how
how babies are made
and that would be a show for my kids
explain me explain for you too okay
because i would love to know how sex
work
i'm curious aren't you yes uh someday
the mystery will be revealed i don't
know but i'm just so that would be a
great show if they actually did have a
show where kids could watch it and learn
yes and the parents don't have to do
that and i tend to over explain i did i
sat my son down to have the
the sex talk and five minutes in i'm i'm
saying i hear myself saying and that's
why the number 69 is not just a number
yeah you know
how did i get there yeah too much
too much they didn't need to know uh
all right now i would i noticed
something in nebraska which i thought
you were great in nebraska i love the
film uh in breaking bad saul is
constantly
being yelled at yeah he's constantly
being threatened he's constantly uh
being uh beaten up or harassed so unfair
yeah
poor assault but then
there's a nice moment in nebraska where
you you get to stand up for yourself and
actually
throw a few punches in a tussle yeah i
love getting into fake fights on tv and
in movies i do it's my favorite thing it
really is because you've my first uh
episode of breaking bad i was out in the
desert and they had dug a grave for saul
and they had a gun to my head
and you know you're you're an adult
you're supposed to be right you're out
in the middle of the desert and it's 2
a.m and it's a sand storm and
people are waving fake guns around
and it's crazy to imagine you're doing
that for a living right
i always think it's
like when i was a kid there was no
nothing more fun than running around and
and fake guns and just pretending to
punch my brothers and then whenever andy
and i get to do a bit where
it's part of our job for me to get
punched through a fake window i'm
delighted i just can't believe we get to
do that yeah that's how i feel and in
this fight in nebraska i actually get in
a few good
shots on this guy all right let's take a
look this is a a clip and i think these
are relatives of yours who are yeah to
extort you yeah yeah let's take a look
at this clip from nebraska
well you may not know it but uh woody
always had a lot of money problems and
the family would help him out from time
to time
so in light of his good
fortune well we thought your family
might want to
make things right oh are you saying you
want money from us well we just figured
seeing as how you know the family took
care of woody and all and guys hey for
real honestly right
woody didn't win anything this is a
total sham
you're a damn liar feed us into your
full
well you want to go
let's do it
watch my face okay i'm on tv
that's your style
[Music]
okay
you know what i love that was the most
realistic fight most you go to someone
punches somebody and they go flying
across the room that's actually how
people feel slap
it starts with slaps it takes a while to
get to punching